i am being inundated by those things  that can only sell me a fix the whole  solution if i believe that i have a hole  and a lot of the feelings that we feel  aren't our feelings because we consume  through every orifice in our body we  consume through our eyes and our ears  and our nose and everything and a lot of  times what is creating the whole  is the fact that we are being targeted  by so many people in the marketing world  in the sales world in the industrial  world all of these worlds that are  competing for our attention there is  actually no hope there is a sensation  that there is a hole but if i actually  get down to it  i'm good  and i don't have a hole